Videoma sponsor olduğu için
6365'e
teşekkür ederiz.
İzlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.
Kurt 250 Overwatch'e
Bu konuda bir ücret almanızı almanız gerek yok. Altium Designer içinden direkt bağlanabilirsiniz. Ayrıca müşterileriniz ya da ekip arkadaşlarınız internet bağlantısı ve internet tarayıcısı üzerinden çalışmalarınızı görüntüleyebilir ve bunlarla ilgili yorum ve değerlendirmelerde bulunabilir.
Altium 365'e entegre, aktro part'ı kullanarak yüzlerce dispiratör arasından elektronik bileşenlerinizi arayabilir ve kendi aralarında kıyaslayabilirsiniz. Açıklamalar kısmında bulunan ücretsiz bağlantıları kullanmaktan ve bu uygulamaları denemekten çekinmeyin.
İzlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.